I'm announcing my candidacy for
president for president
[Applause]
lots of people want to be President it's
gonna be so much easier the second time
I'm repulsed by lots of politicians they
pander to get our attention
a new moon slide all right a former
prosecutor laughs with radio hosts while
lying about the music she liked in
college oh my goodness oh yeah
definitely
two pie but snoop and Tupac didn't even
perform when she was in college and when
they did she was busy imprisoning people
on pot charges Abraham Lincoln
complained that politicians are driven
by a voracious desire for office well
it's not better today not only are they
mad for power they push bad ideas so
here are some of the current candidates
worse are you ready for the post office
to go into banking Bernie Sanders claims
the postal service could make billions
of dollars
by establishing basic banking services
really the people who mishandled mail oh
my god the post office just lost another
billion dollars now they're gonna manage
our money Sanders also wants a ban on
for-profit charter schools why Sanders
has said I believe we do have a moral
obligation to lift up the poorest people
but Sanders would freeze funding for
even nonprofit charters like this one
that helps kids succeed after government
schools failed meeting is worth but it's
rockin awesome Sanders should listen to
his colleague Cory Booker when people
tell me they're against school choice or
charter schools I look at them and say
as soon as you're telling me you're
willing to send your kid to a failing
school in my city then I'll be with you
sensible but unfortunately that was
years ago now that Booker's a democratic
candidate he's quiet about school choice
instead he wants the government to
guarantee everyone a job and to pay many
people's rent we're gonna have a very
aggressive rent
crédit the bad ideas keep coming senator
gillibrand wants to force everyone to
buy fertility treatment insurance real
structural change elizabeth warren plans
to change all kinds of things the
cancellation of student loan debt of up
to $50,000 she'd also ban all oil and
gas drilling on federal land our very
existence is at stake
closing that pay gap Kamala Harris wants
companies to prove they pay men and
women equally there will be penalties if
they don't but salaries vary for lots of
reasons unrelated to sexism president
Harris would also censor the internet we
will hold social media platforms
accountable for the hate infiltrating
their platforms that sounds nice but if
politicians get to decide what's hate
they'll censor any idea they don't like
the First Amendment is one of the
defining features of who we are good for
Joe Biden for saying that but he's got
bad ideas too college should be free
free college is already jacked up
tuition much faster than the rate of
inflation because taxpayers subsidize
too much of college China China China
the Republican frontrunner has bad ideas
too our trade deficit in goods with the
world last year was nearly eight hundred
billion dollars we lost son just trade
800 billion dollars no mr. president we
didn't lose 800 billion dollars the
trade deficit just means foreigners sent
us 800 billion dollars more goods than
we sent them we got products in return
they got this paper which they'll invest
in the u.s. so that's good for us it's
not a problem no it's crazy what they're
saying so many different things
fortunately the incumbent has some good
ideas too we eliminated 30,000 pages of
job-killing regulations from the federal
reg
now the president says he wants to
shrink the code to its 1960 size this
shows how many rules were burdened by
now some Democrats also say sensible
things mayor Pete Budaj criticizes his
opponents for their college for all
freebie I have a hard time getting my
head around the idea that a majority who
earn less because they didn't go to
college would subsidize a minority who
earn more and all the candidates could
learn from congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard
she served in Iraq and says she knows
the costs of war I will end the regime
change wars taking the money that we've
been wasting on these wars and weapons
and investing it and serving the needs
of our people but sadly she wouldn't
give the money back to the people she
wants to spend it on other big
government programs all the candidates
have bad ideas but some are worse than
others let us know in the comments below
who you think has the best and worst
ideas